[Music]
in Nigerian scam new oh no those fools
don't really hire I am a Nigerian prince
give me your mp3 player for $5,000
submitted by burrito in a taco
oh the Crunchwrap supreme an American
man was arrested after scamming three
Nigerian men oh the other way around out
of five hundred and sixty-five thousand
dollars how did that happen you know
what rightfully so he got back at those
[ __ ] whatever you guys were
honest is what if you have the actual
nigerian prince
well he's a prince you got a lot of
money than me to be skimming if they
have almost $400,000 between the three
of them they probably what I'm doing
them the how to do it man his name is
Marco they're famous YouTube bloggers do
yeah so Marvel who's believed to be from
Dallas Texas uh he has been arrested in
Nigeria for scamming three Nigerian
meant and so he kept promising them that
they would get either a green card or an
American passport and so one man he got
scammed out of five hundred and forty
five thousand dollars oh because he
thought that he was investing in one of
the three American companies that he had
in Nigeria [ __ ] and the other two men
were scammed out of ten thousand dollars
with the promise of going to America so
do they get the money back can you
imagine being being the third guy in the
room of like three guys like I got me
for ten thousand damn me too yeah oh
thousand dollars one left market - he
had half a million dollars damn it take
my crap mark up oh look at this loser
look at that crooked ass mom like record
development with the guy with the hook
what is he saying I did it because I was
tired and sick of getting these emails
of helping a Nigerian prince won't you
give these guys a taste of their own
that yeah let's pretend he did can't or
these people were going but if they're
not you're an abundant person and you
should go to jail in Nigeria not in the
u.s. yeah Oh a Nigerian hail at that
like no idea [ __ ] Google it Google
Nigeria with Nigerian jail images I just
picture it being in the jungle with a
lot of huts really being held oh that's
an I'm security president thank you that
was like a bug of disco bro from the
outside don't judge Nigeria like that
why do I look like a [ __ ] Los Angeles
high school with the guard to say no
that's true welcome to freshman year
everybody right now he's pending a court
date but he is in jail and a maximum
security prison - he doesn't look like
you'll survived you know Oh whatsoever
always like one of those guys who can
like negotiate like he's like hey man if
you don't if you don't [ __ ] me up I
promise you I guess you like I'll take
care with you when we get out of here
you like [ __ ] Tyrion Lannister and
[ __ ] you know I'm saying organizers way
out of this it does look like a
fast-talking - or maybe it's a [ __ ] G
and the first day you got married took
somebody's lunch for Fernando no we're
[ __ ] juji juji juji fruit it's not
what you're supposed to do when you're a
president like the first day that you
come in somebody eating a biscuit you
like my biscuit [ __ ] I would just try
to not cause attention you have anything
because you don't know who's a part of
what gang or what the order is I'm just
going to mind my own business but if
someone tries to make me their [ __ ] I'm
gonna suck their dick like it's [ __ ]
the best [ __ ] dick on the whole high
road so they don't pass you around so
they hold on a bunch of the top is
[ __ ] there and I'll be his [ __ ]
nothing like yeah only he [ __ ] me
you're the queen of the prison you want
to really mess with me
yeah really why I got the [ __ ]
baddest [ __ ] here cool I got
backup
you're like a Khaleesi of the prison
yeah just like hanging on an army [ __ ]
why why [ __ ] when you can suck now
you're taxing me if you guys want to
joke Herman his first option just trying
to stay out of the way all right yeah I
feel that's a good idea to slap up this
gun out of someone's hand and you don't
really know people's reputation or high
art game the game like protocol cuz I
know what I would do I don't know what
the rest of the world he do you got a
chill but if anybody tries you you got
to get crazy enough of a real call right
maybe they just won't beat up a
deaf-mute drop it you'll hit me real
quick this I'll definitely try and make
make good friend make big friends you
know because I feel like for one I'm
little I feel like I would people want
to [ __ ] me in jail oh and I got a sweet
butt
so I feel like I want to be prisoner I
know look at a stock I know I said I
would I'm saying I would be desired in
jail and and and I also feel like I'm
little so you know I could you beat up
you know saying I would need big friends
I take it back I'm not I'm not going to
suck anything he already said you can
take a back hand take it back light and
suck a dick yet okay
one is go there with a lot of cigarettes
imma ask all you guys to [ __ ] fill up
my [ __ ] with cartons and cartons of
cigarettes like you're a bubble over
care give my things I'm gonna have my
you know cartons and cartons of
cigarettes no Robin Hood worth more
rama's and cigarettes yeah they don't
beat me up I'm gonna give them [ __ ]
vicodin Robins and cigarettes all right
and then the other option is I'm going
to make them laugh all the time that
they're just gonna be like oh yeah Joe
he's so funny I'm not gonna beat him up
cause he's funny
thank you so funny I want to [ __ ] them
yes
and that's the only way I can take this
beautiful every time they try to [ __ ] me
I'm gonna take a [ __ ] that's a good
place that is a good friend or just be a
very toothy I'm never gonna shower you
know I'm gonna [ __ ] smear [ __ ] all
over my body
and I don't hear it oh you guys here's a
cut just keep a load here underwear
I want wanted to be a surprise I think I
would be what would happen if I went to
prison like I think I'd be even more
upset if I walked in and nobody wanted
to touch me I'm like what's wrong with
me other than any other day everything
anyway what's what's what's wrong with
me why you want to [ __ ] him but you
don't wanna [ __ ] me what's wrong with
you that I tell you at any [ __ ] me right
now
they say close your [ __ ] eyes [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] oh I'll be really upset I
was getting back well there's a lot of
things that have been happening to me
that everybody else is getting but I'm
not getting I think sometimes it's cool
to be invisible
yeah but you saying like I know I'm
happy I didn't get hacked what I'm
saying is that everybody did and they
kind of made me feel that I wasn't
important enough to any one tribe and
then sometimes those people who try to
convert other people into cult and I
didn't get invited so I was like
lightweight what's wrong with me I feel
like if you not wear any lifers you
probably not gonna get [ __ ] on I feel
like that goes for everybody I feel like
only to do is we're going to be in there
for a long time [ __ ] you hey well don't
commit crimes that's really really bad
just like small ones like you're not
going to get a DUI and go into jail
where there's like a lot of lifers there
I can't go to but I'll do anything I can
not to go to prison just don't but
you'll go to a different country and
become a fugitive yes I can't I can't do
it man
I can't wake up through the station
everybody but only a two-month sentence
I'll be bugging to sit and that is
rocking back in well bro it's only been
a day you're lucky though because in
Southern California out of the Asians
there's majority Koreans oh really yeah
I'm down with you much too much isn't
too bad
don't make for a lot of good content
later on it's a really long vacation I
feel like I would cut I would come out
fit but that would be the biggest the
biggest benefit
I don't tell people that billions for 18
years and I'm US alone a single son does
not look like y'all if y'all don't do
that no more Hank in prison I guess
nothing yeah like all they do is smuggle
some bleep out of a hot acuter iPad but
they did good haha you remember the
booty hunter oh yeah love booty I'm a
warrior yeah in that documentary there's
this guy that uses um his sexual favors
as a way to assassinate people in jail
yeah so he'll seduce men and be like
I'll suck yo dick this and that yeah
yeah whatever could do this guy that um
he owed money to but instead of paying
him back he lured him in the corner
started sucking his dick and then he
stabbed the [ __ ] out of him and I'm like
these guys are next-level crazy that's
not even a come up though man it's like
you're watching your children so how'd
you do well what he was dead all up on
the wall I was grabbing him by the did I
just picture that look around he was
telling it proud as if he was an
assassin warrior yes like he was like I
seduced them I put him in a closet I
started sucking watching right in right
in the middle when some was feeling real
good I started stabbing them in the
stomach and I was like I'm crazy I've
seen one it was a buff dude Chris
missing teeth top and bottom right and
he looked like a dude you don't want to
[ __ ] with or whatever so he's telling
the story about a guard and I like
remember him saying so he like suck my
dick so I'm like I [ __ ] it but now he
oh no I don't like the economics of jail
that's 90 cause you suck those guards
dick but now the guard owes him hope you
guys enjoyed that video if you did a
really cool way to communicate that to
us and for you to never miss another
video is by subscribing so click on that
little subscribe button and you'll never
miss an episode for the next episode
click right up here